bonjour je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver ici à Blois j'ai un peu de
buée sur les yeux alors j'enlève mon
masque et je peux l'enlever parce que je
suis assez loin de la ville où se
tiennent les 23e rendez-vous de
l'histoire de Blois c'est l'événement
incontournable pour tous ceux qui aiment
l'histoire et pour tous ceux qui font
l'histoire il y a près de 1000 invités
cette année qui vont débattre d'un thème
passionnant ce thème c'est gouverner
gouverner c'est prévoir disait Adolphe
Thiers mais comment prévoir
l'imprévisible comment gouverner autant
des émotions ces questions et bien
d'autres je les ai posé à mes invités à
qui j'ai donné rendez-vous à Blois
pour commencer on se demandera comment
gouverner face à la peur cette question
se la posera avec le grand historien
Patrick Boucheron dans un second temps
on verra comment les gouvernements
peuvent utiliser la peur pour parvenir
ou se maintenir au pouvoir et cette
question on la posera à la philosophe
Cynthia Fleury et à l'historien de la
République Nicolas Rousselier enfin dans
un troisième temps on se demandera
comment les gouvernants peuvent aussi
utiliser leur propre émotions intimes
pleurer rire par exemple pour gouverner
et cette question on la posera la
journaliste Christine Ockrent et puis
pour terminer un témoin qui sait ce que
c'est que gouverner c'est l'ancien
président de la République François
Hollande gouverner face aux émotions
c'est parti
[Musique]
bonjour Patrick Boucheron bonjour on est
très heureux de vous recevoir ici dans
le château de Blois à l'occasion des
Rendez-vous de l'Histoire vous êtes
professeur historien professeur au
Collège de France et spécialiste de la
peur j'ai d'ailleurs ici ce livre qui
est devenu en quelques années vraiment
un classique en histoire médiévale et
pas seulement en histoire médiévale ça
s'appelle conjurer la peur la peur elle
est partout elle rend parfois difficile
l'art de gouverner on le voit
aujourd'hui la peur du covid la peur de
la fin du monde pour certains l'apport
de la fin du mois et beaucoup de
commentateurs ont fait des parallèles
avec votre période de prédilection le
bas Moyen-Âge en évoquant des peurs qui
qu'on aurait retrouvé par le passé la
porte de la peste mais aussi la peur par
exemple la fin du monde avec le
millénarisme est-ce que l’historien vous
êtes trouve que c'est parallèle sont
légitimes je suis pas vraiment un
spécialiste de la peur mais j'ai regardé
une image cette fresque peinte par
ambrodio Lorenzetti en 1338 10 ans avant
la peste noire mais évidemment il ne le
savait pas et ce que j'y ai vu c'est
effectivement effectivement une manière
par la peinture et plus globalement par
la communication politique de conjurer
la peau et au fond cette peur cette
qualité de peur que Lorenzetti veut
conjurer c'est une peur plus politique
c'est une peur de au fond de ce que que
notre monde que ce à quoi l'on tient ce
qui assure non seulement nos
institutions mais nos existences
s'effondrent avant effectivement la peur
de l'épidémie on a beaucoup
convoqué la concordance des temps avec
la peste en ces temps d'épidémie avant
cette crainte là il y a une peur une
hantise plus politique qui est celle qui
m'intéresse et qui a rapport avec ce qui
nous rassemble à Blois c'est-à-dire les
arts de gouverner la question c'est de
savoir si gouverner sait faire peur si
on peut faire bien gouverner par tant de
peur si au fond avoir peur c'est se
préparer à obéir c'est toutes ces
questions là au fond qui nous
intéressent et est-ce que quand les gens
ont peur parce que le sentiment de peur
n'est pas qu'un sentiment politique ça
peut être un sentiment réel même si tu
as un sentiment de peur est-ce que
d'avoir peur ça rend difficile le fait
de gouverner l'art de gouverner non et
c'est bien pour ça justement qu'il y a
des politiques de la peur c'est que au
fond l'homme apeuré est un homme qui est
préparé à consentir à un pouvoir fut-il
injuste et c'est pourquoi effectivement
quelques pouvoirs tyrannique joue de la
peur en même temps on sait bien que le
slogan inverse n'ayez pas peur peut être
également criminel et que face à des
gouvernements mauvais il y a de quoi
avoir peur et cette bonne peur politique
c'est ce qu'on appelle la vigilance mais
alors le bon gouvernement le bon
gouvernement c'est quoi par rapport à la
peur celui vous dites qu'il est mais ça
veut dire quoi qu'il est équilibré face
à cette peur qu'il désigne la réalité du
du danger et on voit très bien que face
au gouvernement nous aussions sans cesse
entre deux reproches par exemple en
temps d'épidémie allons-y carrément en
faire trop d'en faire pas assez d'une
certaine manière il y a là un dosage qui
est presque impossible à satisfaire
voilà et pourquoi parce que ça Obs le
dit très bien Thomas hopski décrit le
Léviathan vous savez le Léviathan c'est
ce monstre politique qui englobe les les
citoyens apeurés dans la crainte qui
l'inspire et au fond c'est l'idée que
Obs disait je suis né jumeau de la peur
parce que ils croyait on est au milieu
du du 17e siècle il croyait au fond
qu'il y avait un contrat noir entre les
citoyens et l'État que les citoyens au
fond délégués à l'état
l'exorbitant privilège de désigner
l'ennemi et là on est vraiment dans ce
qu'on appelle la souveraineté mais
l'état c'est aussi des gens qui ont un
cœur qui respirent qui sont eux-mêmes
parfois traversés par la peur
potentiellement quand il gouverne
j'aimerais vous montrer ici
3 représentations de peut-être ce
rapport que peuvent avoir les
les gouvernants avec l'information avec
le fait d'apprendre tout à coup qu'il y
a un danger quelque part alors cette
phrase que vous la connaissez bien c'est
la fresque de mantou on est au milieu du
15e siècle à manteau en Italie et il y a
un détail qui vous intéresse c'est ici
où on voit un conseiller qui informe le
prince d'une nouvelle qu'on imagine pas
forcément une très bonne nouvelle vu le
visage du prince et cette image vous la
mettez en relation avec une autre image
on est aussi dans un contexte bien plus
large puisqu'on est le 11 septembre 2001
George Bush est dans une école
maternelle et il reçoit à ce moment là
sur le même mode une information
évidemment très mauvaise catastrophique
dramatique celle des attentats du 11
septembre George Bush reçoit
l'information avec ce visage également
concerné et puis plus récemment dans
l'histoire de France cette fois-ci on
est le 13 novembre 2015 là encore dans
un cadre beaucoup plus large puisque
c'est un match de football au stade de
France et là aussi un conseiller vient à
l'oreille du président François Hollande
l'informer des attentats qui ont eu lieu
à Paris je ne connaissais pas l'image de
François Hollande se faisant apprendre
l'attentat du Bataclan mais je
connaissais évidemment celle de George
Bush et voyons celle de Georges Bush
c'est une déformation professionnelle de
l'historien médiévis que je suis par
transparence j'avais vu cette cette
fresque de Mountain a à mon tout
pourquoi parce que on est dans une scène
alors là qui est une scène du pouvoir
c'est à dire le secret de l'État ce
moment où un conseiller glisse à
l'oreille du prince une information qui
va devenir public mais qui ne l'est pas
encore et qui reste secret au sens
propre et étymologique du terme
c'est-à-dire réservé c'est ce moment
suspendu qui est au fond le moment le
plus intense de la souveraineté et là
évidemment ce qu'on regarde c'est les
yeux du gouvernant ou au fond le
dirigeant prend sur lui la peur qui est
la peur général commune de la société
comme s'il devait l'assumer lui-même et
c'est comme s'il la prenait en charge
oui littéralement comme si d'une
certaine manière cette peur là le
traversait lui-même parce que quand on
dit par exemple la peur du tyran dans la
littérature médiévale ça va dans les
deux sens le tyran évidemment
est un tyran redouté il doit faire peur
il doit se faire craindre mais en même
temps il est pris dans la peur qu'il
suscite il est presque prisonnier de la
hantise de ces sujets et il lui même
c'est la propre de la tyrannie par avoir
peur de la peur qu'il inspire et donc il
y a une sorte de oui de de
nœud de pouvoir qui est très inquiétant
et les images que vous nous montrez au
fond des signes moins une permanence
qu'une transparence c'est que
effectivement comme nous connaissons
l'histoire dès lors que l'événement
surgit fut-il imprévisible nous pouvons
voir à travers lui tout ce que
l'histoire des pouvoirs a armé dans
notre regard est-ce qu'on peut aller
jusqu'à dire que finalement la manière
dont un gouvernant reçoit la peur
définit son type de pouvoir oui d'une
certaine manière on pourrait dire les
choses très simplement
la peur c'est un sentiment qui est
physique qui se ressent et on voit très
bien par exemple nous avons vécu je
dirais presque en direct la chute de la
dictature et on voit dans le regard d'un
voilà on se souvient de chaouchesse coup
on se souvient
la peur change de camp on voit comment
d'une certaine manière la peur qu'on
inspire peut se retourner contre le
tyran ça ça et évidemment avec cette
loupe qui est impitoyable et qui est la
loupe de la télévision ça ne trompe pas
et c'est quelque chose qui est important
parce que cette anthropologie ordinaire
du pouvoir au fond on peut la ressentir
aussi par exemple prenons la Tunisie et
bien la révolution tunisienne
après les printemps arabes en 2011 a été
un moment où effectivement on pouvait en
tout cas c'est ce que nos amis tunisiens
disaient ben voilà ce qui a changé
qu'est-ce qui a changé c'est que je me
promène dans la rue et je n'ai plus peur
de la police et puis c'est revenu et au
fond cette question là est-ce qu'on a
peur de la police c'est une question
très sérieuse en régime démocratique
parce que ça ne vaut pas pour tous les
moments et ça ne veut pas pour tout le
monde et donc au fond c'est un c'est
presque irrépressible mais c'est au fond
indiscutable c'est que si on se met à
avoir peur des forces de l'ordre et
c'est que quelque chose s'est passé on
voit vous écouter à quel point la peur
est un révélateur de l'art de gouverner
des difficultés de l'art de gouverner de
ses failles et aussi de ses dangers et
de ses possibles développement
tyrannique c'était passionnant merci
patrimoine je cite le livre qu'on a
beaucoup évoqué ensemble conjurer la
peur c'est aux éditions Le Seuil et
c'est en point histoire merci beaucoup
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes toujours au château de Blois
derrière moi la charpente sous laquelle
se trouve la salle des États généraux un
lieu de pouvoir et de gouvernement
notamment au 16e siècle avec Patrick
Boucheron nous avons vu à quel point il
est difficile de gouverner face aux
émotions populaires mais on peut aussi
se servir de ses émotions populaires
pour parvenir ou pour se maintenir au
pouvoir pour en parler j'ai donné
rendez-vous à la philosophe spécialiste
du ressentiment Cynthia Fleury et à
l'historien Nicolas Rousselier expert de
l'histoire de la République
[Musique]
je me trouve maintenant ici avec Cynthia
Fleury bonjour bonjour vous êtes
philosophe et professeur aux
Conservatoire national des arts et
métiers et à vos côtés Nicolas
Rousselier bonjour bonjour vous êtes
historien professeur à Sciences
politiques à Paris et l'auteur de la
force de gouverner il y a quelques
années chez Gallimard première question
pour vous votre dernier livre que j'ai
ici Cynthia Fleury s'appelle Sigy lamer
guérir du ressentiment c'est un livre
sur la psychologie mais aussi sur la
politique comment vous en êtes arrivé à
vous interroger sur la question de
ressentiment en politique et si on peut
offrir une définition assez rapide de ce
qu'elle ressentiment bon le ressentiment
de façon un peu rapide c'est une
rumination dans la colère dans l'envie
dans la désignation d'autrui comme bouc
émissaire et dans la désignation de
soi-même comme victime et c'est un
délire qui va se construire autour de ça
donc c'est ni la colère mais c'est la
fixation l'enlisement
l'auto-empoisonnement dans ce sentiment
là la rumination la rumination donc ça
c'est la version la version rapide je me
suis interrogé sur cette question
d'abord parce que j'ai un terrain
clinicien donc j'ai vu que c'était un
objet essentiel en clinique pas
simplement la quête des origines
comprendre pourquoi on a mal mais à un
moment donné malgré la compréhension
d'un mal dire mais j'ai encore mal alors
ça suffit pas de comprendre maintenant
ça suffit pas toujours de comprendre il
faut sublimer et donc cet acte de
sublimation on le rencontre dans le
comment dire le parcours personnel et
puis en revanche pour ma part c'est pas
nécessairement la question du bon
gouvernement mais c'est comment nous
créons des outils institutionnels et non
institutionnels pour endiguer peut-être
la menace la plus forte pour la
démocratie parce que c'est aussi son
exigence première à savoir créer les
conditions de l'égalité mais les
conditions factuelles concrètes et donc
à un moment donné si elle faillit de
fait il y a quelque chose qui vient
renforcer la pulsion ressentis de base
et en même temps on peut aussi avoir un
gouvernement qui joue sur le
ressentiment qui sont nourris Nicolas
Rousselier dans l'histoire c'est quelque
chose d'assez fréquent oui c'est très
fréquent mais je crois que ces questions
de ressentiment et plus largement de
passion pose un problème tout
particulier à la démocratie beaucoup
plus qu'à d'autres régimes la démocratie
effectivement c'est une tentative de
séparation entre raison et passion le
premier geste de la démocratie c'est
d'essayer de se fonder sur le logo c'est
la raison le les décisions raisonnables
rationnelles rationnelles aussi
rationnel en tout cas raisonnable
évidemment dans un parlement une
délibération une discussion une prise de
décision on attend de celui qui prend la
décision celui ça peut être une
collectivité comme une assemblée qu'il
se base sur la raison et qui laisse les
patients au vestiaire mais d'un autre
côté les patients évidemment sont
toujours proches sont toujours là le
problème de la démocratie c'est de faire
toute sa place à la raison pratique et
toute sa place aussi aux émotions je
prends un exemple de Gaulle le 18 juin
vous relisez l'appel du 18 juin 0
émotion dans le texte lui-même c'est
hyper rationaliste nous avons perdu la
guerre parce qu'ils étaient plus forts
nous allons la gagner pour le même
raison quand nous nous serons plus forts
avec plus d'industries plus d'armement
et les Alliés cependant de Gaulle
contrairement à pratiquement tous les
députés et les sénateurs de l'époque qui
avait voté pour la dictature de Pétain
de Gaulle pour partir à Londres il y a
une sorte de passion qu'il a exprimé en
lui-même pour faire ce geste mais après
le geste il y a la politique et il y a
donc la raison mais
les grandes décisions sont quand même
fondées sur ces passions fondamentales
la passion fondamentale de refuser
l'oppression de refuser par exemple la
dictature donc la passion comme moteur
d'action oui Cynthia c'est juste parce
qu'on voit effectivement que la
séparation entre un régime autoritaire
et un régime démocratique elle est assez
faible c'est pas du tout d'un côté il y
a pas d'émotion de l'autre il y a des
émotions ça n'existe pas ça en revanche
c'est
l'orientation la tentative d'orientation
à jante raisonnable de ces émotions et
ça c'est le pari d'une démocratie qui
est effectivement basée sur ce qu'on
pourrait dire une logo graphie cette
considérer que la rationalité publique
la rationalité individuelle aussi mais
aussi la rationalité publique c'est une
construction qui peut exister alors que
c'est pas du tout l'objet d'un régime
autoritaire qui s'intéresse pas du tout
à cette question d'une construction
collégiale de la rationalité publique
mais aujourd'hui on a un certain les
appels des démocratures des régimes qui
sont un peu entre les deux un peu entre
la démocratie et le régime autoritaire
et qui souffle sur les braises de
l'émotion populaire j'aimerais vous
montrer un moment d'un meeting de Donald
Trump on est déjà on est aux États-Unis
on va voir comment Donald Trump est le
type de gouvernants qui est Donald Trump
peut se servir de ce ressentiment quitte
à même peut-être un peu l'entretenir
voire même le créer toute pièce
ils disent que Trump nous divise mais
comment on peut dire ça
ce qu'il veut c'est nous rassembler
c'est ça sur les démocrates qui divisent
le pays
ce sont surtout les médias qui le
divisent
moi je supporte même plus de regarder
CBS le soir
MSNBC 6 bis c'est que des menteurs
moi je regarde Fox News je suis accro
même là bas il y a de plus en plus de
journalistes qui virent à gauche
on est là pour qui alors là on a des
spécimens de militants Donald Trump on
voit
les médias nous mentent nous sommes les
victimes d'une machine médiatique est-ce
qu'on est là au cœur de votre théorie
sur le sentiment c'est toujours
difficile de se permettre voilà mais en
l'occurrence extérieurement oui on
renvoie à ce qu'est à un moment donné
une pulsion ressentie alors pourquoi
parce que on voit bien la généralisation
l'indifférenciation c'est à dire le
grand bain dans lequel tout d'un coup on
met tout et la fin du discernement
c'est-à-dire l'incapacité à un moment
donné à dire telle chose c'est plutôt
ceci telle chose c'est plutôt cela non
on fait un grand bain et ça généralement
c'est un des marqueurs forts d'un
ressentiment et bien évidemment une
binarisation petit à petit une
polarisation qui fait que au lieu
d'aller vers de la complexité vous allez
réduire votre champ d'action et puis
vous réduisez aussi votre champ
d'analyse au sens où c'est eux ou c'est
nous c'est rien
mais ce qui est très intéressant c'est
que les personnes qu'on a entendu les
militants au lieu de parler du
gouvernement au lieu de parler de ce que
fait le gouvernement parler de ce que
font les médias CNN Fox News et donc on
voit qu'en fait il s'attaquait à ceux
qui alimentent la colère qui alimentent
les ressentiments qui alimentent les
patients c'est-à-dire des médias à
certains types de médias qui ne cessent
de mettre de l'huile sur le feu donc ce
qui est intéressant c'est ça il faisait
des commentaires sur les vecteurs de la
passion et du ressentiment plutôt que
s'attaquer aux vrais problèmes
structurels de leur société et Dieu sait
qu'il y en a dans la société américaine
mais revenons un peu en France vous êtes
historien de la République française
est-ce que vous avez constaté vous sur
le temps long qui est votre objet de
l'histoire cette tentation aussi de
jouer sur peut-être les sentiments
victimaires des populations pour se
maintenir au pouvoir ou pour même se
conduire au pouvoir oui enfin le projet
républicain quand on pense aux
républicains du 19e siècle qui avait
fondé leur philosophie politique sur le
positivisme le rationalisme on peut
penser à Gambetta c'est comme comme je
le disais c'est faire sa place aux deux
à la raison et elle a la passion donc
par exemple Gambetta disait quand il
faisait une réunion électorale une
réunion publique il disait assez
auditeurs nous devons mutualiser les
éléments de nos raisons pour en faire
une raison commune mais en sachant en
sachant apprivoiser les patients il
avait un terme intéressant il disait le
gouvernement commence par le
gouvernement de soi-même c'est-à-dire je
parle je vais essayer de donner des
arguments et puis si vous Thomas vous
m'interrompez je c'est la tradition
républicaine on a un dialogue
républicain ce qui veut dire je vous
écoute jusqu'au point où on s'entend et
où la raison sort de ce dialogue sauf
que vous Thomas vous pouvez par exemple
avoir un ressentiment une colère une
colère sacrée pour des raisons
d'injustice profondes et si moi en tant
que républicain démocrate je vous dis
attention vous commencez à être en
colère ça va pas je vous retire votre
ticket d'entrée dans le débat
démocratique parce que la colère n'a pas
de place ici vous avez aussi une une
mise en condition des acteurs légitimes
dans la démocratie qui peut exclure la
colère et le point est toujours très
difficile justement du coup Cynthia
Fleury est-ce qui a pas un risque à
considérer le ressentiment comme un
problème de ne pas prendre en compte les
vrais problèmes les vrais colères des
gens bien sûr c'était
l'instrumentalisation elle peut exister
des deux côtés c'est à dire soit pour
qualifier quelque chose et faire que ce
ressentiment devienne une vérité ou à
l'inverse faire aussi à l'inverse
c'est-à-dire de dire que ce ressentiment
est nécessairement faux qu'il n'a aucune
condition objective etc or c'est pas
aussi simple que ça il y a des
conditions objectifs de renforcement de
la pulsion ressentiment il y a des
injustices économiques sociales etc mais
le ressentiment c'est un pas de plus
c'est à dire que très souvent moi
l'enjeu c'est de montrer quoi l'enjeu
c'est de montrer justement c'est pas de
psychologie l'histoire c'est de
repolitiser l'action politique donc
c'est un moment donné de comprendre que
vous rentrez dans le ressentiment vous
n'allez pas produire une action
politique de type mouvement social
construction édification et lutte contre
les inégalités vous allez produire une
réaction qui va vous emmener vers de la
binarisation et cette binarisation elle
ne va pas produire un progrès historique
elle va produire plutôt généralement une
involution et une régression historique
et pourquoi parce que vous allez donner
pleinement fois à cette passion alors
que dans un univers politique c'est
parce qu'on fait on vient symboliser
c'est-à-dire qu'on utilise cette passion
donc on l'instrumentalise une certaine
manière sauf qu'au lieu de
l'instrumentaliser pour aller dans un
lâcher prise de cette passion on va
essayer de calmer cette passion et
d'orienter pour que elle puisse tout
simplement nous aider à défendre tel ou
telle idéale donc c'est très très
compliqué c'est très très poreux donc
l'enjeu c'est de quoi c'est de produire
un espace politique qui malgré tout
permet c'est vrai à certains types d'É
d'exister et en même temps donne dans
cet espace politique
espace public au lieu de donner des
outils pour
enliser dans cette émotion au même
moment donné des outils pour décrypter
déconstruire cette émotion et l'emmener
vers une tentative de rationalité
publique c'est ça encore une fois le
pari de la démocratie ce n'est pas
simple mais c'est son exigence
une réponse républicaine on peut élargir
pas simplement la République française
la République romaine les républiques
italiennes du Moyen-Âge une réponse est
justement de dissocier des moments et
des instances des instances ou des
institutions c'est que la République est
une pluralité d'institutions qui peut y
avoir un moment ou une institution va
spécifiquement laisser s'exprimer la
colère dans l'Antiquité voilà le tribun
du peuple la fonction tribunicienne donc
c'est très important d'avoir un lieu
propre pour que s'exprime la passion au
lieu qu'on leur dise à la passion non
arrête-toi parce que ça y est tu
commences à être trop violente donc il
faut un endroit où la passion s'exprime
mais c'est un moment ça peut pas être le
seul moment bien sûr d'une prise de
décision il doit y avoir un autre moment
où c'est la prise de décision qui tient
compte de la passion exprimée et qui
tient compte des autres facteurs on
n'imagine pas un chirurgien au moment
d'opérer son patient enfin il faut
l'espérer si on est soi-même spatiant
être pris par ses passions parce que
quelques minutes avant il s'est engueulé
avec un collègue ou quelque chose comme
ça donc on attend de lui qu'il soit
parfaitement maître de lui-même au
moment d'opérer mais ça ne veut pas dire
que préalablement une heure avant en
voyant par exemple l'état de la maladie
du patient il est eu une émotion une
émotion sacrée une empathie pour le
malade par exemple qui est effectivement
très très malade je retiendrai
l'expression de apprivoiser les passions
une question très simple à l'un et
l'autre pour terminer est-ce que vous
êtes vous inquiet par cette dictature ou
ce gouvernement des patients tel qu'on
observe aujourd'hui
moi je suis d'un naturel inquiet donc
déjà
je rassure j'étais inquiète avant pour
voilà donc c'est vrai que la situation
n'a pas aidé à calmer voilà à m'apaiser
donc mais en même temps c'est pas
tellement le problème l'inquiétude c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et ma résolution
c'est un d'en faire quelque chose et
surtout malgré tout je vois et les
comment dire les ingrédients des
difficultés mais je vois également très
sincèrement les ingrédients de possibles
solutions c'est ça la vérité
d'aujourd'hui et donc très clairement
aujourd'hui pour ceux qui veulent ne pas
instrumentaliser ses émotions vous avez
aujourd'hui des alliés très objectifs
que ce soit dans les politiques mais ce
soit dans les associations les
entreprises les artistes etc les lieux
d'économie solidaire pour penser quelque
chose pour compenser cette univers qui
c'est vrai de manière un peu majoritaire
à un relent ressenti miste fort donc le
philosophe EPSI un qui est par nature ne
l'est pas tant que ça l'historien du
coup lui est inquiet oui je suis désolé
il y a pas de diversité moi je sais que
je suis assez inquiet par nature
oui alors la période actuelle est
troublante à tout point de vue mais le
plus troublant c'est que le problème
n'est pas d'exprimer la patience puisque
elle doit s'exprimer et on ne doit pas
lui intimer une forme de caractère
raisonnable sinon elle n'est plus
patiente elle s'exprime plus le problème
c'est le relais voilà le l'embrayage par
quoi fait-on relais de la passion qui
s'est exprimée ce relais n'a pas eu lieu
par exemple pour la crise des gilets
jaunes ou pour un certain nombre de
mouvements sociaux parce que elle
devient peut-être du ressentiment et oui
parce que ce sont les acteurs même de
cette passion qui récusent le fait
d'être relayé et ça c'est très nouveau
dans l'histoire de la démocratie
bon c'est passionnant on aurait pu
continuer longtemps je cite votre livre
c'est une qui a fleuri qui vient de
paraître chez Gallimard Siji la mer
guérir justement du ressentiment et
quant à vous un livre un peu plus ancien
mais passionnant la force de gouverner
c'était aussi chez Gallimard merci
d'avoir été mes invités merci
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours à Blois au
rendez-vous de l'histoire on a vu à quel
point les émotions populaires peuvent
être utilisées par ce qui nous
gouvernent pour prendre le pouvoir ou
pour se maintenir au pouvoir mais les
gouvernants utilisent de plus en plus
leur propre émotions il pleure il rit
ils sont en colère et tout cela à des
fins politiques nous allons en parler
avec la journaliste Christmas
la reine Christine dans un château où
c'est très cohérent Christine Ockrent
bonjour bonjour Seigneur Thomas je
trouve que ce décor vous convient Rafi
merci on a commencé cette bonne base
alors surtout le côté austère vous
n'êtes publiés aux éditions de
l'Observatoire la guerre des récits
Trump Poutine la pandémie et le choc des
empires les récits ça m'intéresse
beaucoup on réfléchit ensemble depuis le
début de l'émission sur gouverner autant
des émotions vous avez vu beaucoup d'un
politique au cours de votre carrière
vous les avez interviewé est-ce que vous
sentez que de plus en plus et même des
femmes politiques bien sûr et ce que
vous avez le sentiment que de plus en
plus ils mettent en avant leur propre
émotions il pleure ils sont en colère en
surjouit un peu les choses comme un
avantage comme un exercice politique la
communication contemporaine dans les
démocraties oui évidemment avec Trump on
atteint le paroxysme de la chose
puisqu'on a affaire en fait à
bateleur de téléréalité c'est d'ailleurs
ainsi qu'il a été connu et apprécié de
profonde donc Trump a fait de l'émotion
de la mise en scène de l'émotion enfin
de l'émotion qui le concerne c'est
rarement ça concerner rarement quelqu'un
d'autre donc Trump oui c'est
véritablement le phénomène dans ce qu'il
a de plus caricatural dans les régimes
autoritaires non regardez Poutine
dont le visage
remodelé paraît-il au fil des années
exprime très peu d'émotions ça m'a
beaucoup frappé en essayant de trouver
des infos sur ce qui se passe en Russie
en temps de pandémie il y a eu très très
peu d'informations fiables qui sont
sorties mais on voyait Poutine
dans une mise en scène
s'adressant donc réfugiés en fait dans
sa propriété près de Moscou il y a
toujours et s'adressant au gouverneur
des diverses régions russes qui l'a
laissé les reines longues pour ne pas
avoir à lui-même les tâches domestiques
ça n'intéresse pas beaucoup et puis
c'était une manière aussi que ce soit
les gouverneurs qui assument les
décisions impopulaires mais là vous
n'avez pas de manifestation d'émotions
ni même de compassion
s'agissant des démocraties on voit bien
que la communication politique a changé
tout ça ça dépend aussi de la génération
à laquelle appartiennent les dirigeants
vous voyez effectivement un Boris
Johnson qui a fait de l'émotion de la
mise en scène de son propre personnage
la clé de son parcours politique à lui
alors justement puisque vous en parlez
on l'avait prévu et ça tombe très bien
on va voir effectivement comment Boris
Johnson on a une vidéo de lui sortant de
l'hôpital il a été très malade très
atteint par le coronavirus il y a
quelques mois avant ça il avait pris
plutôt à la légende on le voyait serrer
des mains un peu partout changement de
ton complet quand il en sort et vous
allez voir il parle de lui il parle des
autres avec énormément d'émotions
j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudront pas de
citer particulièrement deux infirmiers
ils sont restés à mon chevet pendant 24
heures quand il n'y avait pas d'autre
solution
il y a Jenny de nouvelles Zélande et
Luis du Portugal près de Porto
la raison pour laquelle mon corps a
finalement commencé à avoir assez
d'oxygène c'est parce qu'à chaque
seconde
il réfléchissait il se préoccupait de
moi il me donnait les soins dont j'avais
besoin un demi
un infirmier portugais ce qui pour
l'architecte un peu comment dire un peu
confus du brexit ne manque pas de sel et
au même moment sa compagne a couché si
ma mémoire est bonne d'un petit garçon
qui a eu droit au prénom
de les Portugais alors l'émotion est
partout et elle est aussi vous l'avez
dit chez les jeunes générations de ceux
qui nous gouvernent et notamment chez
notre président de la République jamais
vous montrer un de ces tweets un de ces
messages sur le réseau social Twitter
c'était juste après justement de
l'incendie dramatique de la cathédrale
Notre-Dame de Paris et regardez et lisez
avec moi les mots qu'il emploie
Notre-Dame de Paris en proie aux flammes
émotion de toute une nation pensée pour
tous les catholiques et pour tous les
Français comme tous nos compatriotes je
suis triste ce soir de voir brûler cette
part de nous
l'expression de la tristesse personnelle
de l'intimité quelle fonction elle a ici
mais le président de la République qui
s'exprime un moment où
nous avons tous et au-delà même
de la France je me souviens très bien
moi j'étais aux États-Unis en ce
moment-là ça a été une émotion intense
et collective l'émotion peut-être
sincère n'est pas seulement fabriquée
mais il appartient au président de la
République ça fait partie de son rôle
d'exprimer l'émotion que n'aurait-on pas
dit si son message alors certes
aujourd'hui ça passe par Twitter avec
les limites du nombre de signes etc mais
tout cela
c'est de la communication mais c'est
aussi la fonction même qu'il exige mais
parfois on peut aussi s'en servir à des
fins véritablement politique comme une
arme politique j'aimerais vous montrer
les larmes de Barack Obama on est après
une énième tuerie de masse dans une
école aux États-Unis et vous allez voir
comment les larmes deviennent non
seulement une forme d'émotion
évoquée intime montrer à l'oeil public
mais aussi un outil de pouvoir politique
à chaque fois que je pense à ses enfants
ça me rend malade
et d'ailleurs ça arrive tous les jours
dans les rues de Chicago
[Applaudissements]
donc
nous devons tous demander à notre
congrès d'avoir le courage de se
positionner
face au lobby des armes nous devons tous
faire front pour protéger nos
concitoyens nous devons demander à nos
gouverneurs législateurs et entreprises
de faire leur part pour rendre notre
communauté plus sûre
donc on est en 2012 au moment de la
terrible durée de Sandy ou des enfants
de 6 ans sont assassinés on voit bien
comment ils utilisent ça pour ensuite
pousser le législateur à agir donc alors
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui la larme est plus
utile politiquement que l'argument
rationnel
mais l'alarme a toujours fait partie
déjà
politique et bien avant les réseaux
sociaux et bien avant les caméras
l'histoire et
parsemé d'émotions et parsemer
d'utilisation de ces émotions
s'agissant d'Obama
qui fait référence en plus à sa propre
jeunesse et plus encore à celle de son
épouse qui ont le sait a toujours été
plus active et plus émotionnelle que lui
sur toutes les questions
sociales lui étant plus monstre froid
mais évidemment l'utilisation de
l'événement l'émotion créée par
l'événement et derrière le déclenchement
d'une manœuvre politique un moment si ma
mémoire est bonne ou il n'a pas la
majorité au Congrès oui mais il est
président des États-Unis il fait le job
donc il y a quand même toujours un
moment où on ne peut pas et surtout nous
autres journalistes donc en fait c'est
le métier aussi d'essayer d'exprimer ou
de traduire
sinon des émotions en tout cas des
analyses qui sont aussi
imprégnées de ce que nous ressentons
donc tout cela me semble-t-il fait
intensément partie de la période
contemporaine
simplement il y a des gens qui sont plus
sincères que d'autres et d'autres qui
sont encore plus habiles que certains
justement c'est la dernière question que
je voulais vous poser en tant que
journaliste qui avait observé qui
observé ces gens là comment démêler le
vrai du faux est-ce que le journaliste
son travail c'est d'aller voir la
sincérité ou l’insécurité et puis
éventuellement de la débusquer mais tout
dépend tout dépend des circonstances
tout dépend aussi de la nature de
l'exercice journalistique comme vous le
savez le but c'est de poser des
questions et d'essayer d'avoir des
réponses
ça reste quand même le verbe merci en
tout cas pour vos réponses merci
Christine d'avoir été mon invité ici à
Blois je rappelle le titre donc de votre
livre qui vient de sortir aux éditions
de l'Observatoire la guerre des récits
c'est sur la manière par laquelle les
gouvernants ont affronté différemment et
notamment en termes de communication et
d'émotions la crise du coronavirus c'est
tout à fait ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes toujours à Blois à
l'occasion des 23e rendez-vous de
l'histoire on a entendu des historiens
une philosophe une journaliste évoquée
l'art de gouverner autant des émotions
on a eu envie de confronter tout cet
apport au regard d'un témoin un témoin
qui sait ce que gouverner veut dire j'ai
donné rendez-vous à François Hollande
[Musique]
bonjour François Hollande bonjour on est
très heureux très honoré aussi de vous
recevoir pour cette émission pour clore
cette émission qui était consacrée au
thème de l'année au rendez-vous de
l'histoire de Blois gouverné et gouverné
face aux émotions alors gouverner ça
vous connaissez plutôt vous avez été
président de la République rappelons-le
entre 2012 et 2017 et vous avez gouverné
aussi face à un temps d'émotion
exacerber pour commencer j'aimerais vous
montrer une image ou plutôt trois images
que j'ai montré tout à l'heure à
l'historien Patrick Boucheron et
j'aimerais avoir votre commentaire sur
ces images la première image on est sur
une phrase que du Moyen-Âge à mantou et
vous avez le prince qui annonce une
information ensuite vous avez George
Bush en 2001 et on est ensuite au Stade
de France le 13 novembre 2015 qu'est-ce
qu'on ressent à ce moment là quand on
apprend un événement aussi grave que les
attentats qui sont en train de se
dérouler à Paris
d'abord des images comme celle-là
peuvent ne rien dire parfois un
conseiller vient vous voir pour vous
faire part d'une information qui n'a pas
d'intérêt mais qui pour lui permettra
d'être important mais il peut y avoir
une image comme celle-là qui va avoir
une signification y compris pour le
grand public pourquoi un moment un
conseiller en l'occurrence c'était un
policier venez vers moi et me donner une
information quelle information mais
communiquer à ce moment-là c'est celle
d'un acte terrorisme puisque j'ai
entendu une détonation je ne sais pas
exactement quel est son origine sa
nature ses effets et ce policier vient
me dire que en réalité il y a eu une
tentative d'attentat sans doute une mort
d'homme et qu'il y a un risque d'autres
attentats
que dois-je faire j'ai cette information
elle est douloureuse parce que je sais
que nous sommes dans un grand match de
football il y a 50 000 personnes qui
sont rassemblées est-ce qu'il n'y a pas
un terroriste qui s'est introduit dans
le stade donc je dois montrer du sang
froid et une préoccupation
le sang froid c'est de ne pas quitter
mon siège au moment où cette information
m'est donnée sinon c'est pour beaucoup
de ceux qui peuvent être là autour de
moi l'idée qu'il se passe quelque chose
et que la détonation en fait est un acte
terroriste mais je dois aussi être
présent le plus rapidement possible dans
un lieu qui va être celui de la prise de
décision regardons le bas du football je
ne peux pas avoir toutes les
informations je ne peux pas prendre une
décision donc je dois la suite de cette
information réguler mon temps restez
suffisamment à ma place pour ne pas
inquiéter et trouver une opportunité
pour quitter mon siège pour prendre ma
décision il y a une troisième dimension
comme moi qui m'intéresse c'est que j'ai
lu dans le livre de Karim Rissouli que
vous aviez aussi vos enfants qui
potentiellement pouvaient être au cœur
des actes terroristes donc ne pas
inquiéter prendre des décisions mais
est-ce que vous personnellement vous
avez peur à ce moment-là
j'ai un de mes enfants qui est au stade
de France donc pour lui je n'ai pas peur
ou je n'ai pas plus peur que pour tous
les autres mais je m'inquiète pour ceux
qui ne sont pas au stade de France mais
je vais pas même en tant que père de
famille tout a pour donner en appelant
mes propres enfants je fais en sorte
d'appeler leur mère pour qu'elle puisse
elle-même savoir comment elle peut les
retrouver et ensuite je n'ai pas trop
d'inquiétude parce que j'ai le retour
qu'ils sont en sécurité et est-ce que
vous dites vous vous dites très vite que
il y a un risque dans les jours qui
suivent que la peur
prennent par au sein de la population
française j'ai d'abord un premier
sentiment c'est est-ce que la peur ne
peut pas saisir le stade lui-même c'est
à dire que si les informations sont
connues si par les textos les gens qui
sont dans le stade de France savent
qu'il y a eu un attentat aux portes du
stade la tentation de cette sortir du
stade c'est-à-dire la seule
interprétation que j'ai de l'acte
terroriste lui-même créé une panique que
des gens se marchent dessus des
centaines de personnes pourraient ainsi
être blessées ou mourir et puis ensuite
la peur oui bien sûr c'est ce qui dans
cette nuit là mais j'ai connu d'autres
nuits dramatiques peut être le sentiment
général c'est à dire avoir peur ce que
la peur peut avoir comme conséquence
quelquefois c'est de se protéger nous
avons peur donc nous faisons attention
mais aussi la peur c'est la peur de
l'autre c'est la peur de l'inconnu c'est
la peur de l'avenir et c'est ça
l'inquiétude que j'ai toujours c'est que
ce que les terroristes
et notamment les islamistes veulent
faire c'est nous nous faire peur pour
que nous puissions nous diviser
justement on vous écoute un discours
très important
c'est nous faire peur nous saisir
d'effroi
il y a effectivement de quoi avoir peur
il y a les froid mais il y a face à
l'effroi une nation qui sait se défendre
qui s'est mobilisé ses forces et qui une
fois encore sera vaincre les terroristes
se saisir de ce sentiment pour en faire
quelque chose de positif
oui faire que la peur soit un sursaut et
pas un repli faire que la peur puisse
être un engagement et pas retrait faire
que la peur puisse être une mobilisation
collective et pas un acte individuel
donc c'est ça comme chef de l'État ma
responsabilité à ce moment-là c'est pas
de nier la peur comment ne pas avoir
peur quand des terroristes mettent des
bombes ou tu des gens sans distinction
nous avons peur mais la peur comme on le
dit le proverbe n'efface pas le danger
donc il faut que face à la peur nous
soyons plus fort encore dans votre livre
qui est votre dernier livre répondre à
la crise démocratique vous montrez bien
comment les régimes autoritaires aussi
peuvent parfois utiliser la peur comme
un instrument de pouvoir et comment les
régimes démocratiques sont un peu en
difficulté face à ce type de de menace
comment vous considérez vous ça est-ce
que vous dites pas que les démocraties
aussi parfois peuvent se saisir de la
peur comme un instrument qui est pas
cette tentation là aussi
les régimes autoritaires prétendent
qu'ils sont mieux placés que les
démocraties pour répondre à des défis et
notamment le terrorisme ou la crise
sanitaire en disant finalement nous nous
pouvons imposer très vite des décisions
donc pas besoin de nous embarrasser de
délibération des libertés donc nous
sommes plus forts c'est une erreur la
démocratie a des qualités que qu'un
régime
dictatorial ou anti-démocratique pour un
produit c'est-à-dire la capacité de
rendre les les forces plus intelligentes
de nous de nous mettre en situation par
l'association de tous d'être capable de
surmonter y compris les attaques comme
celle-là la meilleure preuve c'est que
les démocraties ont gagné contre tous
les totalitarismes toujours et que les
démocraties on a pas été les premiers à
vivre le terrorisme ont toujours vaincu
le terrorisme parce que il y a quelque
chose de plus essentiel dans la
démocratie c'est on sait pourquoi on se
bat on se bat pour la liberté on se bat
pas simplement pour vaincre notre peur
les régimes autoritaires ils se battent
pour qui pour le chef pas pour les gens
il y a un historien américain c'est le
Coré Robin qui a écrit un livre très
passionnant sur la peur justement et je
vais vous montrer cette citation il vous
fait réagir il dit utilisez la menace
des ennemis à l'extérieur comme prétexte
pour réprimer les ennemis de l'intérieur
est-ce que ça peut être une tentation
aussi y compris au sein des démocraties
oui d'abord il y a des démocraties qu'on
appelle libérales qui ont utilisé toutes
les peurs pour lutter contre les
opposants on l'a vu y compris dans
l'affaire du covid mais ça peut être une
tentation même pour des démocrates de se
dire finalement nous avons des ennemis
nous avons des gens qui te respectent
pas les lois profitons-en pour remettre
en cause des libertés essentielles on
les trouvera et on les punira davantage
que ce serait possible tant de quiétude
et de paix et c'est pour ça que ça
savait été posé comme question jusqu'où
peut-on aller dans le sens de la fermeté
sans entraver nos libertés et c'est un
équilibre qui n'est pas facile et qui
suppose que il y a contre-pouvoir
notamment le Parlement mais aussi les
les juges les magistrats ce qu'on
appelle l'autorité judiciaire pour nous
dire non vous pouvez pas aller aussi
loin parce que vous ne pouvez pas faire
d'un état d'urgence un état permanent
vous ne pouvez pas autoriser des
perquisitions dans n'importe quelle
condition vous pouvez pas assigner la
résidence des gens que vous n'aimez pas
on peut comprendre qu'ils peuvent être
des dangers parce que sinon qu'est-ce
que vous allez faire demain dans la
période que j'ai traversé il y avait la
question des fichiers S et certains
notamment dans l'opposition à droite il
faut enfermer tous les fichiers S mais
les fichiers par définition c'était des
personnes qui ont suivi qui n'est pas
encore commis d'acte qui n'était pas
pédalement responsable donc comment
allait-on les mettre dans dans un camp
et en disant vous êtes des éléments
dangereux on va vous mettre de côté non
c'est pas possible parce que c'est pas
parce qu'on serait des naïfs ou parce
qu'on serait des innocents ou parce que
on serait des laxistes non c'est tout
simplement parce qu'il y a des règles
c'est toujours un risque parce que quand
un fichier
commet un acte on dit mais pourquoi vous
ne l'avez pas arrêté pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas été dans une police
préventive mais c'est pas parce que je
regarde un individu qui me paraît
dangereux que je peux l'arrêter et c'est
précisément le dit la difficulté de
gouverner en ces temps d’indignation
permanente où on est parfois rattrapé
par l'émotion populaire oui et
quelquefois condamné par l'émotion
populaire qui vient comme on vadicte
dire pourquoi vous ne l'avez pas empêché
cette attentat je me souviens d'une
scène assez douloureuse pour ce qui me
concerne j'étais venu sur les lieux des
attentats notamment au Bataclan avec le
préfet de police qui nous accueillait le
Premier ministre le milieu intérieur de
l'époque et on est allé auprès du
Bataclan on l'a vu ces femmes et ces
hommes qui sortaient à gare de ce lieu
et
rentrant quelqu'un sur le balcon m'a dit
pourquoi vous n'avez pas empêché ça
pourquoi vous vous n'avez pas
dissuadé ces terroristes de commettre
cet acte je pouvais comprendre cette
indignation et on voit bien ce que
l'émotion je pouvais lui répondre je ne
l'ai pas fait je laisse ça à d'autres
par voie de balcon à rue venez me
chercher je vais vous trouver et on va
se parler non j'ai compris ce qu'il me
disait je comprenais sur la dignation
j'avais envie de lui et combien d'actes
terroristes a-t-on nos péchés mais
surtout que nous sommes en guerre d'une
certaine façon que nous avons toujours
des ennemis qui peuvent nous provoquer
et nous nous abîmer nous attaquer la
difficulté du discours rationnelle face
à un discours et ça c'est le point le
plus important
si les démocrates perdent la raison
alors le risque est sérieux la raison
c'est ce qu'ils font de la démocratie ça
veut pas dire qu'on n'a pas d'émotion
j'ai des émotions je suis capable pas
simplement parce que j'ai une
responsabilité nous sommes tous capables
de garder la raison alors même que nous
sommes submergés par l'émotion par
l'idée de la revanche
parfois de la punition qui est
nécessaire mais nous devons garder la
raison c'est intéressant c'est
exactement ce que nous disait votre
place Nicolas Rousselier tout à l'heure
l'historien qui nous est à quel point la
République et la raison et la démocratie
faisait bon ménages et devait faire bon
ménage j'ai une dernière question on a
évoqué aussi avec Christine Ockrent tout
à l'heure les émotions visibles de ce
qui nous gouvernent de vous j'ai pas le
souvenir de vous en train de pleurer
est-ce que vous avez déjà
résister à cette tentation ou céder à la
tentation de jouer de vos émotions
intimes à des fins même politique
peut-être non jamais voulu jouer
et je me suis néanmoins retenu de
laisser paraître mes émotions pour ne
pas laisser penser que j'étais moi-même
touché par ce que certains notamment les
terroristes islamistes pouvaient nous
infliger mais il se trouve que
participant à une cérémonie à la suite
des attentats des terrasses et du
Bataclan j'ai été donc à court des
Invalides et je voyais ces blessé qui
était là je voyais ces familles de
personnes disparues et il y avait des
chansons
il faisait un froid terrible et le
froide d'une certaine façon gelée aussi
mes émotions et quand les chansons
étaient entonnées
je pense qu'une larme a coulé
merci ça sera le mot de la fin gouverné
face aux émotions merci beaucoup d'avoir
été mon invité c'est ainsi que sa chèvre
rendez vous à Blois il me reste à
remercier les équipes de France 3 centre
Val de Loire et le château de Blois qui
nous a accueilli avec une extraordinaire
générosité
[Musique]